restrictions renforcées pour certains
voyageurs ceux qui viennent d'inde du
brésil du chili d'afrique du sud
d'argentine mais aussi de guyane ils
vont se voir imposer une mise à
l'isolément de dix jours des territoires
dits à risque où les variants circule
beaucoup misé allemand obligatoire à
l'arrivée sur le territoire a déjà été
imposé dans certains pays dès le début
de la pandémie exemple israël ou la
corée du sud
en france la mesure entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de voyageurs l'aéroport
charles de gaulle regarder non je
pensais c'est très bien pour la santé de
tout le monde et je trouve ces nouvelles
stations qu'ils ont mis en mesure sont
très bien pour tous les pays et la
quarantaine pour les personnes qui sont
ils ont attrapé le virus
je pense que c'est très bien de les
mettre en quarantaine pour avoir moins
de cas surtout en france en turquie
partout dans tous les pays et je trouve
ça très très bien même si on n'est pas
positive il faut il faut rester il faut
s'isoler pour dix jours chez nous donc
on va le faire et après des jours on va
faire un autre test pour voir si tout va
bien ou pas c'est très nécessaire c'est
une question de vie ça va